- Ласкаво просимо назад до курсу «Розуміння квантової
інформації та обчислень».
Мене звати Джон Ватрус, і я
технічний директор IBM Quantum Education.
Це шостий урок серії та другий урок
другого розділу, присвяченого квантовим алгоритмам.
На попередньому уроці ми розглядали модель обчислень із запитами
та побачили, що в цій моделі квантові алгоритми можуть
забезпечити разючу перевагу
над класичними алгоритмами, включно з експоненційною перевагою у випадку задачі Саймона.
На жаль, модель запитів
насправді не має жодного прямого чи безпосереднього
практичного значення.
Поняття «чорного ящика» є дуже корисною
абстракцією, але нам ще є що зробити, якщо ми хочемо застосувати
інсайти, отримані
з моделі запитів, до більш стандартного обчислювального середовища, де вхідні дані задаються як рядки бітів,
а не у вигляді оракулів або чорних ящиків.
Головна мета цього уроку — закласти фундамент,
з якого ми зможемо це зробити.
Ось огляд уроку. Більшу частину уроку ми зосередимося
на обчислювальній вартості,
або, іншими словами, на тому, наскільки складними є різні
обчислювальні задачі та як ми можемо вимірювати цю складність.
Грубо кажучи, це зводиться до того, як довго нам доведеться чекати
завершення обчислень і зрештою які
обчислювальні проблеми
ми можемо розв'язати, а які
залишаються поза нашими можливостями.
Почнемо з
кількох прикладів: факторизація цілих чисел та обчислення найбільшого спільного
дільника, або НСД скорочено.
Це дуже хороші приклади для ілюстрації
основних принципів, і обидва вони до того ж
дуже актуальні для алгоритму Шора, який ми
розглянемо на наступному уроці,
тож ми фактично
отримаємо подвійну користь від цих прикладів.
Потім ми обговоримо поняття обчислювальних витрат більш загально та способи їх вимірювання.
Є багато різних
способів зробити це, але ми зосередимося переважно на тому, як це можна зробити з circuit моделями обчислень,
зокрема Boolean circuits
та quantum circuits.
Тут акцент буде на алгоритмах, а не на комп'ютерному
обладнанні, наприклад, і нас більше цікавитиме
те, як витрати на
виконання алгоритму масштабуються в міру зростання розміру конкретних задач, а не скільки секунд,
хвилин або годин
займає те чи інше обчислення.
Ідея, що мотивує цю точку зору, полягає в тому, що алгоритми мають
фундаментальне значення.
Навіть сьогодні ми
використовуємо алгоритми, розроблені
дуже і дуже давно, і цілком природно, що вони будуть розгортатися
на дедалі більших
екземплярах задач із використанням швидшого та надійнішого обладнання в міру розвитку технологій.
І те, як вони масштабуються, говорить нам дуже багато
про те, наскільки вони корисні і наскільки корисними залишатимуться надалі.
В останньому розділі уроку ми звернемося до критично важливого завдання — виконання класичних обчислень
на квантових комп'ютерах. Це важливо не тому, що ми сподіваємося замінити класичні комп'ютери
квантовими,
що видається вкрай малоймовірним найближчим часом, якщо це взагалі колись станеться, а радше тому, що це відкриває
багато цікавих можливостей
для квантових алгоритмів.
Зокрема, як тільки ми навчимося виконувати класичні обчислення
на квантових комп'ютерах, вони стають доступними для квантових
алгоритмів як підпрограми,
тож ми зможемо ефективно
використати все, що знаємо про класичні алгоритми, у пошуку квантових обчислювальних переваг.
Класичні комп'ютери, які ми маємо сьогодні, — це справжні технологічні дива.
Вони неймовірно швидкі, але не настільки, щоб жодна обчислювальна задача
не виходила за межі їхніх можливостей.
Деякі обчислювальні задачі
настільки складні за своєю природою, що хоча алгоритми для їх розв'язання у нас є, жоден комп'ютер на планеті Земля сьогодні
не є достатньо швидким, щоб довести ці
алгоритми до завершення навіть на помірно великих вхідних даних протягом людського життя
або навіть протягом
терміну існування самої Землі.
Щоб пояснити докладніше, давай розглянемо
задачу факторизації цілих чисел.
Формулювання задачі дуже просте. Вхідні дані — ціле число N, не менше двох, а вихід — це
розкладення N на прості множники,
тобто список простих множників числа N разом зі степенями, у які ці прості числа потрібно піднести,
щоб отримати N при
множенні їх усіх разом.
Звичайно, ми завжди можемо перемножити прості множники в будь-якому порядку, але крім порядку розташування,
розкладення на прості множники завжди унікальне для кожного значення N.
Цей факт називається
основною теоремою арифметики, і якщо ти хочеш
дізнатися про неї більше, її можна знайти
на самому початку
багатьох книг з теорії чисел.
Як дуже простий приклад, ось розкладення числа 12
на прості множники.
Це два в степені два
помножити на три в степені один.
WEBVTT
Не дивно, що
комп'ютер може сказати тобі це в мить ока, просто ітеративно шукаючи
прості множники.
Ось іще один приклад. Я не намагатимуся читати це число.
Воно становить приблизно 3,4 кватуордецильйони, і мушу визнати, що мені дивно, що для цього взагалі є назва,
але так чи інакше, воно має 46 десяткових цифр, і тут ти можеш побачити
його розкладення на прості множники.
Комп'ютер може сказати тобі і це. Я розклав це число за допомогою методу факторизації, включеного до бібліотеки символьної математики
для Python,
і це зайняло кілька секунд — не особливо довго, але затримка була помітною.
І звичайно, метод factor N знаходить це розкладення на прості множники не шляхом наївного пошуку простих множників.
Насправді він використовує гібрид
різних алгоритмів, зокрема один під назвою
«алгоритм кольорових рядів», який є алгоритмом факторизації,
більш досконалим, ніж наївний ітеративний
пошук простих множників, і хоча це може здатися
досить великим числом,
як вхідні дані для обчислювальної задачі воно насправді зовсім невелике.
Це лише 46 символів.
Ось іще один приклад. Це число, що має 309 десяткових цифр.
Якщо записати його в двійковій нотації, воно має 1 024 біти, і саме тому
воно називається RSA1024.
Розкладення цього числа на прості множники наразі невідоме.
Це число взяте з
задачі RSA-факторизації, яку проводили
RSA Laboratories з 1991 по 2007 рік.
Вони пропонували грошові призи
за розкладення на прості множники різних чисел зростаючого
розміру, зокрема цього, яке коштувало 100 000 доларів США,
але цей приз так і не був отриманий.
Безпека криптосистеми RSA
з відкритим ключем базується на складності
факторизації цілих чисел.
Якщо ти можеш розкласти число на множники, ти
можеш зламати систему, тому мета задачі полягала в тому, щоб відстежувати
стан мистецтва факторизації.
Підсумок такий: факторизація цього числа
перевищує наші поточні можливості.
Наскільки нам відомо, ця
задача занадто складна для класичних комп'ютерів,
щоб розв'язати її на практиці.
Найбільше число з RSA-задачі, яке до цього часу вдалося розкласти на множники, до речі, має 250 десяткових цифр.
Можливо, це трохи важко
прочитати на екрані, але ось розкладення на прості множники
числа RSA250.
Це було зроблено у 2020 році за допомогою алгоритму, відомого як «решето числового поля», і це була колективна зусилля, що залучали десятки тисяч
комп'ютерів по всьому світу.
Тепер розглянемо іншу
обчислювальну задачу — обчислення найбільшого спільного
дільника, або НСД скорочено,
двох невід'ємних цілих чисел.
Ось формулювання задачі. Вхідні дані цього разу складаються з двох
чисел — N та M,
і ми припустимо, що
вони не обидва дорівнюють нулю.
Мета — обчислити
НСД цих двох чисел, тобто найбільше ціле D, яке ділить обидва числа N та M,
і якщо ти думаєш про
розкладення N та M на прості множники, то побачиш, що НСД — це добуток усіх простих чисел,
які діляться і на N, і на M, піднесених до мінімуму степенів, що з'являються у двох
розкладеннях на прості множники.
Отже, це пов'язано із задачею
факторизації цілих чисел, але виявляється набагато, набагато простіше
для комп'ютерів. Ми можемо обчислювати НСД чисел із тисячами цифр
в мить ока.
Мені немає сенсу показувати тобі приклади на екрані, бо ми могли б заповнити
весь екран цифрами, і це все одно були б
легкорозв'язувані екземпляри цієї задачі.
Але якщо тебе це цікавить, перейди за посиланням у описі відео на сторінку підручника для цього уроку, і ти знайдеш там комірки з кодом
для обчислень подібного роду, включно з обчисленнями
НСД великих чисел, і можеш спробувати їх самостійно.
Питання в тому, чому можна так легко обчислювати НСД?
Відповідь полягає в тому, що у нас є ефективні
алгоритми для обчислення НСД.
Серед них — алгоритм Евкліда, відкритий понад 2 000 років тому, але є й інші
ефективні алгоритми обчислення НСД.
І звичайно, ми говоримо тут про класичні алгоритми, тому виникає інше питання.
Чи може існувати ефективний
класичний алгоритм факторизації цілих чисел,
який дозволив би нам розкладати числа на зразок RSA1024
в мить ока?
Відповідь — так. Цілком може існувати ефективний класичний
алгоритм факторизації, і наразі ми не знаємо жодного способу
виключити цю можливість. Все, що ми можемо сказати, — це те,
що ми його ще не знайшли.
У всіх відомих нам класичних
алгоритмах факторизації ми все ще по суті
шукаємо множники,
і це робить числа на зразок
RSA1024 недосяжними для нас.
Ефективні алгоритми НСД,
з іншого боку, просто не працюють таким чином.
Вони не шукають
найбільший спільний дільник. Вони фактично просто
будують його за допомогою механічної процедури, яка приблизно порівнянна за вартістю
з множенням тих самих
двох чисел, і я скажу про це трохи більше пізніше в уроці.
WEBVTT
Звичайно, усе це підводить нас
до алгоритму Шора, який ми побачимо на наступному уроці — це ефективний квантовий алгоритм
для обчислення розкладення на прості множники, але нам ще є що охопити, перш ніж ми до нього доберемося.
Далі ми поговоримо
про математичний апарат, за допомогою якого можна вимірювати обчислювальні витрати
різних алгоритмів,
зокрема тих, про які ми вже говорили.
Зауважимо, що ми зосередимося дуже вузько на circuits — це лише невеликий шматок
набагато ширшої теми.
Почнімо з дуже загального погляду на звичайне обчислення
з попереднього уроку, тобто зокрема ми не думаємо
про задачі із запитами,
а думаємо про
задачі, де вхід задається явно як двійковий рядок.
Як я казав на попередньому уроці, ми, звичайно, могли б дозволити
й інші символи, якщо захотіли б, але давай просто не ускладнювати і дотримуватися двійкових рядків
як для входу, так і для виходу.
Саме обчислення можна моделювати або описувати різними способами, наприклад, за допомогою моделі машини
Тьюрінга,
Boolean circuits, quantum circuits або програм, написаних
мовою на зразок Python чи будь-якою іншою мовою за твоїм вибором.
Як я казав хвилину тому, ми зосередимося на
circuits — Boolean та quantum.
Для початку приділимо трохи більше часу обговоренню входу та виходу, які, за нашим припущенням, є двійковими рядками.
Використовуючи двійкові рядки, ми можемо кодувати найрізноманітніші
математичні об'єкти, наприклад числа, вектори,
матриці, графи,
описи молекул, наприклад, а також списки всіх цих об'єктів та інших.
Як дуже простий приклад: якщо ми хочемо кодувати невід'ємні
цілі числа як двійкові рядки, можна використовувати двійковий запис.
У цій таблиці ти побачиш перші 13
невід'ємних цілих чисел разом з їхніми двійковими
представленнями або кодуваннями.
У третьому стовпці ти можеш побачити довжину
кожного з цих кодувань, тобто загальну кількість бітів, необхідних для кодування,
а ось проста формула, яка точно показує, скільки бітів
потрібно загалом для будь-якого невід'ємного цілого числа N.
Зверни увагу, що
довжина кодування, як правило, набагато менша,
ніж саме число.
Вона є логарифмічною від числа.
RSA1024, наприклад, має кодування довжиною 1 024, але саме число, звичайно, набагато більше.
Ця схема кодування працює
для невід'ємних цілих чисел, але якщо ми хочемо обробляти
довільні цілі числа, включно з від'ємними, ми
можемо просто додати знаковий біт.
Ми також можемо дозволити будь-яку кількість провідних нулів у цих кодуваннях, якщо хочемо, щоб кодування
заповнювали блок бітів або регістр фіксованого розміру,
достатньо великого. Іноді це дуже зручно.
Це не єдиний спосіб кодувати цілі числа як рядки бітів.
Є й інші способи зробити це, але це доволі
стандартний підхід.
Для інших видів об'єктів, які можуть бути входами або виходами обчислювальних
задач, що нас цікавлять, ми можемо розробити
інші схеми кодування.
Наприклад, подумай, як
ти міг би закодувати вектор або граф як двійковий рядок, або подумай, як ти міг би закодувати
два двійкові рядки в
один двійковий рядок, використовуючи лише символи нуль і один без пробілу чи будь-якого іншого символу
для розділення двох рядків. Безумовно, є способи
зробити це, і насправді у нас є великий ступінь свободи
щодо того, як саме це робити.
Часто не буде єдиного стандартного або загальноприйнятого способу кодувати те, про що ми говоримо,
як двійковий рядок,
але це нормально — ми можемо просто вибрати один або придумати новий, якщо хочемо.
З суто формальної точки зору ми думаємо про обчислення як про по суті механічні перетворення рядків бітів,
і специфіка будь-яких
схем кодування, які ми використовуємо, безумовно, важлива на якомусь рівні.
Тим не менш, коли ми проектуємо та
аналізуємо алгоритми, ми зазвичай не дуже турбуємося про специфіку
схем кодування.
Якщо ти попросиш двох різних людей придумати спосіб кодувати, скажімо, молекули певного
виду як двійкові рядки,
можна очікувати, що вони придумають різні способи, але якщо це були б розумні люди, які знають свою справу,
можна також обґрунтовано очікувати, що це буде досить
простий обчислювальний процес — перекласти туди й назад між двома схемами кодування,
швидше за все, що вимагає дуже
простого обчислення, яке було б досить легким порівняно з реальним обчисленням,
яке нас цікавить.
Підсумок такий: деталі щодо схем кодування, які ми використовуємо, часто є другорядними, і наш акцент — на самих
алгоритмах.
До речі, нічого з цього не буде проблемою для цього уроку. Ми головним чином зосереджуватимемося на задачах, пов'язаних з цілими числами, які, за нашим припущенням, закодовані в двійковому форматі,
але це варто знати.
Загалом, для будь-якого виду задачі, про яку ми говоримо, довжина входу означає
кількість бітів, необхідних для кодування вхідних даних,
і ми розглядаємо довжину входу як розмір екземпляра будь-якої задачі, про яку ми думаємо.
Тепер розглянемо
саме обчислення, яке представлене
синім прямокутником на цьому рисунку.
Спосіб вимірювання
вартості цього обчислення — підрахунок кількості елементарних операцій, яких воно вимагає.
Інтуїтивно, елементарна операція — це операція над невеликою фіксованою
кількістю бітів або qubits,
яку можна виконати швидко й легко, наприклад обчислення AND
двох бітів.
WEBVTT
На формальному рівні
є різні способи визначити, що таке елементарна операція, залежно від того, яку
обчислювальну модель ми використовуємо.
Наприклад, елементарною операцією може бути один крок машини Тьюрінга, якщо ми використовуємо цю модель.
Для цілей цього уроку ми зосередимося на circuit моделях, як я вже зазначав, і зокрема на quantum
та Boolean circuits.
Коли ми працюємо з circuits, прийнято вважати, що кожен gate представляє елементарну операцію.
Ми вже бачили кілька різних quantum gates у серії,
зокрема X, Y та Z gates, Hadamard gates, S та T gates,
controlled NOT gates, swap gates, Toffoli gates та Fredkin gates.
Ми також говорили про query gates у контексті моделі запитів, але ми не будемо працювати в рамках моделі запитів у цьому уроці, тому не будемо зараз турбуватися про
query gates.
Ми також бачили, що будь-яка унітарна операція над будь-якою кількістю qubits
може розглядатися як gate, якщо ми хочемо.
Але для вимірювання вартості це не буде дуже корисним, тому ми просто
виберемо набір gates
і розглядатимемо його як наш набір елементарних операцій.
По-перше, включимо
single qubit unitary gates, які ти бачиш тут,
а саме X, Y та Z gates,
Hadamard gates та S і T gates, а також їхні обернені
або спряжено транспоновані.
Насправді нам не потрібні всі ці gates. Як тільки ми маємо Hadamard та T gates, ми можемо реалізувати решту,
але заради зручності ми включимо їх усі.
Ми також включимо controlled NOT gates, і вони будуть єдиними
multiple qubit gates у нашому наборі.
І нарешті включимо single-qubit вимірювання в стандартному базисі, щоб ми могли реально отримувати класичну інформацію
з наших circuits.
Якщо ми зосередимося лише на унітарних gates і забудемо про
вимірювання на мить, ми отримаємо те, що називається
universal gate set.
Це означає, що
будь-яка унітарна операція над будь-якою кількістю qubits може
бути реалізована точно
або довільно близько
за допомогою quantum circuit, побудованого лише з цих gates.
Іншими словами, це
достатньо хороший набір gates, з яких можна побудувати будь-яку унітарну
операцію.
Не обов'язково точно, але ми можемо досягти наскільки завгодно доброго
наближення.
Для цього може знадобитися багато gates, і насправді не важко зрозуміти, що іноді так і має бути,
але тим не менш це завжди можливо.
Довести, що це universal gate set, — непроста задача, і ми не будемо обговорювати, як
це робиться в серії,
але це досить добре відомий факт, і насправді є різні
способи його довести.
Є й інші наборами gates, які іноді використовуються
замість цього, наприклад Toffoli gates, Hadamard gates та S gates крім вимірювань,
але це досить стандартний вибір.
Отже, підсумовуючи, ці —
quantum операції, які ми розглядатимемо як елементарні.
Для Boolean circuits
ми розглядатимемо ці чотири gates як
елементарні операції: AND gates, OR gates, NOT gates та FANOUT.
FANOUT, до речі, не
завжди вважається gate, але нам буде
важливо це враховувати, як ми побачимо пізніше в уроці.
Подібно до того, що у нас є для
нашого стандартного набору quantum gates, цей набір трохи надлишковий.
Тобі не потрібні і AND, і OR. Ти можеш створити будь-який з них за допомогою іншого з трьома NOT gates,
але включити обидва не шкодить — це просто зручно.
Як ти вже, можливо, знаєш, це universal gate set
для детермінованих обчислень, тобто будь-яка функція
від бітів до бітів
може бути реалізована за допомогою Boolean circuit, складеного з gates цієї колекції.
Знову ж таки, так само, як ми
мали для quantum circuits, це не означає, що кожна функція може бути ефективно реалізована
за допомогою Boolean circuit,
і справді більшість функцій
можуть бути реалізовані лише з дуже великими circuits
з тієї простої причини, що функцій дуже багато
і не всі вони можуть мати малі circuits. Просто малих circuits недостатньо на всіх.
Універсальність легше
довести в цьому випадку, ніж у квантовому, як виявляється.
Тож якщо ти ще не
знаєш, як це довести, подумай над цим і
подивись, чи зможеш розібратися, якщо схильний до цього.
Тепер, коли ми вирішили, які
gates ми дозволимо і які вважатимемо
елементарними операціями, ми можемо подумати про те, скільки з них
потрібно для виконання
різних обчислень.
Для цього ми
скористаємося цим визначенням розміру circuit.
Це визначення підходить як для
Boolean, так і для quantum circuits, і воно дуже просте.
Розмір circuit — це
загальна кількість gates, які він містить.
Наприклад, якщо ми повернемося
до того самого прикладу, який ми вже бачили кілька разів — нашого Boolean circuit для обчислення виключного АБО двох бітів,
ми побачимо, що його розмір дорівнює семи,
бо є сім gates: два FANOUT gates, два NOT gates,
два AND gates і один OR gate. Якби ми вирішили не рахувати
FANOUT gates, що є поширеним, розмір був би п'ять,
але ми рахуємо FANOUT gates, тому розмір дорівнює семи.
WEBVTT
Розмір circuit
відповідає кількості елементарних операцій,
які потрібно виконати.
Тож якби ми виконували
ці операції послідовно, розмір показував би
нам, скільки часу це займе,
тому можна думати про розмір circuit як про час послідовного виконання.
Ось так ми
вимірюватимемо обчислювальну вартість для цілей цього уроку.
Є й інша властивість
circuits, яку також можна розглядати як кількість часу,
необхідного для виконання circuit — це глибина circuit.
Якщо бути точним, глибина —
це максимальна кількість gates на будь-якому шляху від вхідного дроту до вихідного дроту,
що еквівалентно кількості шарів gates, необхідних
для створення circuit, де шар — це сукупність gates,
які можуть бути виконані одночасно, бо у них немає
спільних дротів.
Наприклад, наш circuit
з попереднього прикладу має глибину чотири, і ми можемо безпосередньо з діаграми бачити, що є чотири шари.
FANOUT gates можна
виконувати одночасно, NOT gates можна
виконувати одночасно, і AND gates також можна
виконувати одночасно.
Тому можна думати про глибину circuit як про час паралельного виконання.
Глибина circuit — це безумовно цікаве й важливе поняття, і є деякі дуже
витончені методи, які можна використовувати для зменшення
глибини, необхідної для деяких обчислень, іноді досить суттєво, але це просунута тема,
і ми не будемо говорити про неї набагато більше в цій серії.
Тож знову ж таки ми
вимірюватимемо обчислювальну вартість через розмір circuit або, іншими словами,
кількість елементарних операцій, необхідних для виконання обчислення.
На початку уроку ми говорили про задачу
факторизації цілих чисел і побачили, що час, необхідний алгоритму для розв'язання цієї задачі,
може зростати зі збільшенням довжини входів, і це, як правило,
саме та проблема, на якій ми зосереджуємося
при аналізі алгоритмів.
Тобто нас цікавить, як масштабуються витрати на виконання алгоритмів в міру збільшення входів.
Звичайно, таке масштабування — не єдине, що має значення.
Наприклад, нас може просто цікавити знаходження множників
числа RSA1024 і все.
Тож у такому випадку ми говоримо про
один екземпляр задачі, де нічого не зростає.
Але коли ми думаємо про алгоритми, те, як масштабуються їхні витрати, має велике значення і говорить нам багато
про алгоритми.
Ця точка зору
відповідає ідеї про фундаментальну важливість алгоритмів, і як я говорив раніше,
з часом і розвитком технологій вони будуть застосовуватися до
дедалі більших входів.
Але зверни увагу: хоча входи до обчислювальних задач
можуть зростати в розмірі, circuits не ростуть.
Кожен circuit має фіксований розмір.
І з цієї причини, якщо ми хочемо описати
алгоритм за допомогою circuits, нам насправді знадобиться сімейство circuits для цього,
і під сімейством circuits ми маємо на увазі колекцію circuits, яка стає дедалі більшою, щоб ми могли обробляти входи
в міру їх зростання. Наприклад, розглянемо класичний детермінований алгоритм
для задачі факторизації цілих чисел, можливо, заснований на пробному діленні, але специфіка не дуже важлива
для цього прикладу.
Ми могли б в принципі
описати такий алгоритм за допомогою сімейства Boolean circuits, де якщо ми хочемо розкласти число на множники,
двійкове представлення якого має N бітів, ми беремо circuit CN з нашого сімейства і подаємо число,
яке хочемо розкласти,
на вхідні біти цього circuit.
Іноді ми можемо вибирати параметризацію цих
circuits по-різному, тому не завжди N-й circuit матиме N вхідних бітів,
але це досить типовий підхід. Природно, що зі збільшенням довжини входів ми очікуємо, що circuits
у цьому сімействi ставатимуть більшими,
відображаючи той факт, що
факторизація чотирибітових чисел значно простіша, ніж факторизація 1 024-бітових, наприклад.
Тому, маючи це на увазі, ми вимірюємо вартість такого
алгоритму функцією, яка говорить нам, скільки
елементарних операцій
потрібно для кожної можливої довжини входу, і ми можемо робити це як для класичних, так і для квантових алгоритмів.
Як приклад, розглянемо задачу додавання цілих чисел, що, звичайно, набагато
простіше, ніж факторизація
або навіть обчислення НСД.
Для простоти припустимо, що і N, і
M є невід'ємними цілими числами та що вони представлені
двійковими рядками однакової довжини.
Як ми могли б побудувати Boolean circuits для додавання цих двох чисел?
Ну, почнімо з алгоритму — стандартного алгоритму додавання, який є двійковим аналогом методу
складання чисел олівцем на папері, який ми всі, гадаю, вивчали, тому починаємо з
молодших значущих бітів,
додаємо їх і отримуємо молодший
значущий біт результату разом з переносом,
який треба враховувати
при переході до наступної позиції. І продовжуємо рухатися по бітах, генеруючи вихідні біти
разом з бітами переносу,
поки не дійдемо до кінця.
WEBVTT
Цей метод може бути
досить прямолінійно виражений у термінах Boolean circuits.
Один зі способів думати про це — почати з невеликого circuit для додавання двох однобітних цілих чисел.
Це дасть нам число
від нуля до двох, де менший значущий біт — це XOR вхідних бітів,
а більш значущий біт, або біт переносу, якщо хочеш, — це AND двох вхідних бітів.
Іноді circuit, що виконує ці
дві операції разом, називають напівсуматором.
Це добре працює, коли
є лише два вхідних біти, але якщо ми хочемо складати цілі числа, які мають більше одного біта кожне,
нам потрібно якось
обробляти біти переносу.
Тому ми можемо каскадно з'єднати
два напівсуматори і взяти OR бітів переносу, які вони виробляють, щоб створити так званий повний суматор,
який по суті є Boolean circuit для додавання трьох однобітних
чисел разом.
І маючи повний суматор, ми можемо складати числа
просто каскадно, переходячи від молодшого значущого біта
до старшого значущого біта. Ми по суті просто реалізуємо стандартний алгоритм додавання за допомогою повних суматорів для
обробки бітів переносу.
Яка ж вартість цього обчислення?
Нам потрібно сім елементарних
gates для кожного XOR gate, що означає 10 gates для напівсуматора,
і отже 21 gate для повного суматора, який складається з двох напівсуматорів плюс одного OR gate.
Тому зрештою, якщо наші вхідні числа обидва мають AND бітів, нам потрібен напівсуматор для
молодшого значущого біта
і повний суматор для кожного іншого біта, і кінцевий результат — 21 помножити на N мінус один плюс 10, або 21N мінус 11 gates загалом.
Якби ми з якоїсь причини вирішили не
рахувати FANOUT gates і включили XOR
gates у наш набір gates, нам знадобилося б п'ять N мінус
три gates загалом.
Добре знати точно, скільки gates або елементарних операцій потрібно для виконання різних обчислень,
як ми щойно побачили на прикладі цілочисельного додавання.
І звичайно, якщо ми хочемо реально реалізувати ці обчислення, нам потрібно знати ці деталі.
Але якщо ми завжди заглиблюємося в такі подробиці, особливо для більш
складних алгоритмів, ми дуже швидко захлинемося в деталях,
які в багатьох випадках мають
другорядне значення.
Один зі способів спростити справи, дуже поширений в аналізі алгоритмів, — це використовувати нотацію «O велике»,
яка дозволяє нам виражати
та порівнювати швидкості зростання досить простим
і зручним способом.
І ось ти можеш бачити визначення, яке лежить в основі цієї нотації.
Припустимо, що у нас є
дві функції G і H, які, для простоти, можна вважати такими, що приймають невід'ємні цілі
значення,
хоча це насправді не обов'язково. Можливо, G і H представляють витрати різних обчислень, наприклад.
Тоді ми кажемо, що G є «O великим» від H, що традиційно записується
зі знаком рівності ось так.
Якщо G(N) не більше якоїсь
додатної константи C, помноженої на H(N), поки N достатньо велике.
Отже, це стосується того, що
відбувається, коли N стає великим.
Формально, «достатньо велике» означає, що існує такий вибір N нуль, щоб нерівність була справедливою
для всіх N, не менших за N нуль.
Ключовим тут є те, що ці
числа C і N нуль фіксовані.
Вони можуть бути будь-якими числами,
але якими б вони не були, вони не можуть змінюватися зі зростанням N.
Якщо ти ніколи раніше не бачив
такого визначення, може знадобитися деякий час, щоб до нього звикнути, і ти можеш знайти ресурси,
які пояснюють цю концепцію
значно докладніше,
ніж я можу в цьому уроці.
Зазвичай ми вибираємо
функцію H простою, щоб виразити щось про те, наскільки швидко зростає функція G.
Наприклад, функція, значення якої дорівнює 17 помножити на N у кубі мінус 257
помножити на N у квадраті плюс
65 537, є «O великим» від N у кубі, і ти можеш підігнати цей
приклад до визначення,
вибравши C і N нуль відповідним чином.
Наприклад, якщо взяти C рівним 18, то вираз справді буде не більше 18 помножити на N у кубі
при достатньо великому N.
Пов'язуючи цю нотацію назад з
прикладом цілочисельного додавання, ми тепер можемо сказати, що існує сімейство Boolean circuits
для додавання невід'ємних цілих чисел, таке що розмір N-го circuit, тобто того, що працює
для входів довжини N,
є «O великим» від N. Фактичний розмір CN
за нашим аналізом становив 21 помножити на N мінус 11,
але це «O велике» від N.
Тепер не завжди розумно відкидати деталі таким чином, але тут це має сенс,
бо це виявляє суттєву природу стандартного алгоритму додавання, яка полягає в тому, що його вартість масштабується лінійно
від розміру чисел,
які ми складаємо, і цей вираз не чутливий до деяких низькорівневих
деталей нашої моделі,
таких як саме які gates ми вважаємо елементарними операціями.
Наприклад, якби ми вирішили, що XOR gates слід вважати
елементарними операціями, або що FANOUT gates не повинні
вважатися gates, або і те, і інше,
все одно цілочисельне додавання можна обчислити з вартістю «O велике» від N.
WEBVTT
Ось іще один приклад
обчислювальної задачі — множення цілих чисел.
Подібно до додавання, можна запитати, яка вартість
цього обчислення.
Якщо розглянути стандартний
алгоритм множення, тобто двійковий аналог методу множення чисел,
якого навчають у початковій школі,
який по суті є просто
зсувом і додаванням при роботі з числами у двійковому форматі, ми виявимо, що існують Boolean circuits розміром «O велике» від N у квадраті
для множення N-бітних цілих чисел.
Я не буду докладно розглядати це. Звичайно, circuits трохи
складніші, ніж для додавання, але якщо ти подумаєш про спосіб
роботи стандартного
алгоритму множення, це не стане несподіванкою.
По суті, нам потрібно
виконати приблизно N додавань, кожне з яких має лінійну вартість, і тому отримуємо
квадратичну вартість загалом.
Це можна узагальнити. Якщо одне число має N бітів, а інше — M бітів, нам потрібні circuits
розміром «O велике» від N помножити на M.
Тут, до речі, ми використовуємо розширення нотації «O велике» з кількома змінними, і її можна розширити таким чином,
і якщо тебе цікавлять
конкретні деталі, я відсилаю тебе до змісту підручника
для уроку, посилання на який знову є
в описі відео.
Насправді можна
перемножити два N-бітних цілих числа так,
щоб це було асимптотично краще за стандартний алгоритм множення.
Зокрема, алгоритм множення Шьонхаге-Штрассена
перемножує два N-бітних цілих числа з вартістю «O велике» від N помножити на довжину N
помножити на довжину довжини N. Тому при великих N, наприклад
десятки тисяч бітів,
це насправді ефективніший
спосіб множення, але він складний і накладні витрати роблять його непрактичним
для менших чисел.
Тож додамо множення
до нашого списку прикладів.
І для простоти наведемо вартість за стандартним алгоритмом множення, що дорівнює «O велике» від N у квадраті.
Отже, знову ж таки, ми зосереджуємося на суттєвій природі цієї вартості, яка полягає в тому, що вона масштабується квадратично
або субквадратично при використанні асимптотично кращих методів.
Ми також можемо розглянути
задачу цілочисельного ділення, яка точно сформульована на екрані.
Тут ми говоримо про обчислення частки та залишку, тому відповідь складається
з двох цілих чисел — Q та R.
Знову ж таки, існує стандартний
алгоритм ділення, який також має квадратичну
вартість, і подібно до множення,
насправді існують
асимптотично кращі алгоритми.
То як же порівнюються алгоритми НСД?
Алгоритм Евкліда виявляється
має квадратичну вартість, і саме це я мав на увазі
раніше в уроці, коли говорив, що ми можемо обчислювати НСД
приблизно з такою ж вартістю, як і множення двох чисел.
Знову ж таки, існують
асимптотично кращі алгоритми в тому ж дусі,
що й для додавання та множення,
хоча вартість трохи
вища в цьому випадку, принаймні наскільки нам відомо.
Згадаю лише ще один приклад задачі для цього списку — модульне піднесення до степеня.
Тут є три вхідних
числа — K, M та N, і мета — обчислити
N у степені K за модулем M,
тобто залишок
від ділення на M.
Це зовсім не очевидно, але ми можемо обчислити модульне
піднесення до степеня з вартістю qubit, тобто «O велике» від N у кубі для N-бітних цілих чисел.
Для цього не треба спочатку обчислювати N у степені K, а потім обчислювати залишок.
Навіть просто записати N у степені K може знадобитися експоненційно багато бітів, тому такий підхід не спрацює.
Натомість ми можемо використовувати алгоритм,
який називається алгоритмом піднесення до степеня, або повторним зведенням у квадрат, де все робиться за модулем M,
і ми використовуємо біти
K для ітеративного зведення у квадрат та множення так,
щоб все це працювало.
Отже, це
дорожче за інші, але ми все одно можемо досить швидко виконувати
модульне піднесення до степеня для чисел
з тисячами бітів.
То як же вартість цих задач порівнюється з факторизацією цілих чисел?
Якщо почати просто і
думати про пробне ділення, де спочатку перевіряємо, чи є два множником вхідного числа,
потім перевіряємо три і так далі, ми отримаємо досить
дорогий алгоритм: «O велике» від N у квадраті, помноженого на
два в степені N поділити на два.
Кожне ділення займає квадратичний час, і в найгіршому випадку нам потрібно шукати прості множники аж до квадратного кореня вхідного числа,
і ось звідки береться N
поділити на два. Якщо на цьому етапі ми не знайшли
простого множника, можна просто зупинитися, бо тоді
вхідне число саме є простим.
Це надзвичайно дорого, бо N фігурує в показнику в цьому виразі, тобто цей
алгоритм має експоненційну вартість.
Натомість усі приклади, які ми маємо в цьому блоці, мають те, що ми називаємо поліноміальною вартістю, де N підноситься до певного степеня,
але цей степінь завжди фіксоване число, яке не зростає зі
зростанням довжини входу.
У цих випадках степені
дорівнюють одному, двом та трьом.
Я повернуся до порівняння поліноміальної та експоненційної вартості через хвилину, але спочатку завершимо
з тим, що ми знаємо про факторизацію.
WEBVTT
Раніше я згадував
«решето числового поля» — це найкращий
алгоритм факторизації, який ми маємо з погляду масштабування вартості.
Фактично вартість цього алгоритму строго не доведена, бо вона пов'язана з деякими відкритими питаннями теорії чисел,
але конjectured, що вона має
вигляд, який ти бачиш тут.
Цього разу «O велике» знаходиться в показнику, але я відкладу
цю деталь убік.
Ключовий висновок такий: це значно краще
за пробне ділення, тому що хоча N і
з'являється в показнику,
воно підноситься до степеня 1/3, і це відповідає значно нижчій вартості, і саме тому цей алгоритм
може обробляти числа на зразок RSA250, тоді як пробне ділення
точно не може.
Проте він все одно є експоненційним у тому сенсі, що степінь N з'являється в показнику, і тому в результаті
він все ще не може впоратися з
числами на зразок RSA1024.
Тепер дозволь сказати трохи більше про поліноміальну вартість
порівняно з експоненційною вартістю.
Ми кажемо, що алгоритм
має поліноміальну вартість, якщо його вартість є «O великим» від N у степені B,
де B може бути будь-яким додатним числом, але ключове те, що B має бути фіксованим, тобто воно не змінюється
зі зростанням довжини входу N.
Для прикладів, які ми щойно бачили, а саме цілочисельне додавання, множення, ділення, обчислення НСД
та модульне піднесення до степеня,
B дорівнювало або
одному, двом, або трьом.
Тому все це —
алгоритми з поліноміальною вартістю.
Але коли ми говоримо про поліноміальну
вартість більш загально, B може бути будь-яким додатним числом.
Воно може навіть бути мільйон,
але має бути фіксованим.
Як дуже грубе узагальнення, алгоритми з поліноміальною
вартістю, як правило, розглядаються як ефективні алгоритми.
Це безумовно надто спрощена думка, але як грубий орієнтир можна думати про алгоритм з поліноміальною вартістю
як такий, що якось використовує
структуру задачі для побудови розв'язку, на відміну від підходу
грубої сили
або вичерпного пошуку
у дуже великому просторі.
Звичайно, алгоритм, вартість якого масштабується як N у степені мільйон
для входів довжини N,
розумно
не можна вважати ефективним, і ми не очікуємо, що його можна буде запустити на великих входах.
Але навіть алгоритм N у степені
мільйон повинен робити щось розумне, що якимось чином відображає структуру
будь-якої задачі, яку він розв'язує, щоб уникнути експоненційного масштабування вартості, яке було б пов'язано з
вичерпним пошуком у великій области.
І на практиці виявлення алгоритму з поліноміальною вартістю — це дійсно лише перший
крок до ефективності.
Якщо задача є важливою
і хтось відкриває самий перший алгоритм з поліноміальною
вартістю для неї, можливо, з дуже великим показником,
можна обґрунтовано бути впевненим, що розробники алгоритмів
знайдуть покращення, завдяки яким цей показник зменшиться.
По суті можна
думати про існування алгоритму з поліноміальною вартістю
для задачі як про демонстрацію можливості
розв'язання цієї задачі
на обґрунтовано великих входах, але може знадобитися ще багато роботи, щоб досягти справжньої ефективності.
У теорії складності прийнято говорити, що вартість алгоритму масштабується субекспоненційно, якщо вартість є «O великим» від двох в степені N
у степені epsilon для кожного додатного дійсного числа epsilon, і якщо вона не є субекспоненційною,
то вона є експоненційною, або навіть може бути суперекспоненційною, наприклад два в степені два в степені N,
що є подвійно-експоненційним,
але доти, доки вихід
не є суперекспоненційно довгим, кожну задачу насправді можна
обчислити за допомогою Boolean circuit
з експоненційною вартістю. Тому важлива відмінність тут — між поліноміальною
та експоненційною вартістю.
Нам невідомі класичні алгоритми з субекспоненційною вартістю для
факторизації цілих чисел.
Наприклад, вартість «решета числового поля» не є «O великим» від двох в степені N у степені epsilon, коли epsilon дорівнює 1/3 або менше,
тому воно не задовольняє це визначення.
Це безумовно дуже розумний алгоритм, але він все одно є решетом, і ми все одно фактично шукаємо
у дуже великому просторі, щоб знайти множники заданого числа.
Як ми побачимо на наступному уроці, насправді існує квантовий алгоритм з поліноміальною
вартістю для факторизації цілих чисел.
Алгоритм Шора має поліноміальну вартість, і зокрема він має вартість qubit, подібно до модульного піднесення до степеня.
Ще один клас задач, з яким ти можеш бути знайомий, — це клас NP-повних задач.
Я не буду пояснювати, що таке NP-повні задачі в цьому уроці, але ти можеш знайти інформацію про них,
якщо зацікавлений.
Є гіпотеза, що
жодна з цих задач не має субекспоненційної вартості.
Це по суті версія на основі circuit того, що іноді називають
«гіпотезою експоненційного часу», але поки що нікому не вдалося
довести це.
Фактично, ми навіть не можемо довести, що не існує алгоритмів з лінійною вартістю для NP-повних задач.
Це просто дуже важко, принаймні наскільки нам відомо, виключити можливість
майбутнього відкриття неймовірно творчого
алгоритму для цих задач.
WEBVTT
Ось рисунок, що
ілюструє зв'язок між поліноміальною та експоненційною вартістю.
На осі X — довжина входу для будь-якої задачі, яку ми розглядаємо, а вісь Y представляє
вартість розв'язання цієї задачі,
або можна думати про це
як про час, необхідний для розв'язання задачі.
Алгоритм з експоненційною вартістю
може масштабуватися ось так.
Для коротких входів вартість може бути не особливо великою, як, наприклад, факторизація
числа 12,
але зі збільшенням довжини входу вартість зрештою різко зросте.
Алгоритм з поліноміальною вартістю,
з іншого боку, може мати масштабування, що виглядає ось так.
Вартість все одно зростатиме загалом зі збільшенням входів, і вона може навіть коштувати більше, ніж алгоритм з експоненційною вартістю для деяких входів,
але зрештою вона буде
набагато менш дорогою, ніж алгоритм з експоненційною вартістю, і не зростає так само різко
як алгоритми з експоненційною вартістю.
Тому, якщо уявити, що у нас є якась максимальна вартість, яку ми готові витратити, або максимальний час, який ми готові чекати відповіді,
якщо хочеш думати про час, то алгоритм з експоненційною вартістю буде працювати лише для входів
до певної довжини,
тоді як загалом алгоритм
з поліноміальною вартістю дозволить нам розв'язувати
задачу для більших входів.
Ось чому, наприклад, ми легко можемо обчислювати НСД для чисел з тисячами
бітів, але в найгіршому випадку
ми не можемо розкласти числа такого розміру на множники.
В останній частині уроку ми звернемо увагу на реалізацію класичних обчислень
на квантових комп'ютерах.
Конкретніше, ми
побачимо, що будь-яке обчислення, яке може виконати Boolean circuit, також може виконати quantum circuit
приблизно з такою ж вартістю. Більше того, це можна
зробити чистим способом, що важливо, якщо ми хочемо виконувати ці обчислення
як підпрограми всередині
більших квантових обчислень, і я поясню, що маю на увазі під «чистим», коли ми заглибимося в обговорення.
Ми збираємося використовувати
Toffoli gates у цьому процесі.
Пригадай, що Toffoli gates — це controlled-controlled-NOT gates, тому їх дія на стани стандартного базису
така, як ти бачиш тут на екрані.
Зверни увагу, що ми також можемо
думати про Toffoli gates як про query gates
для функції AND.
Це не означає, що вони є query gates у буквальному сенсі. Як я згадував на початку уроку, ми не працюємо в рамках
моделі запитів на цьому етапі,
але скоріше їхня дія слідує тому самому шаблону, що й query gate.
Ми можемо думати про двійкові значення A і B як про входи функції AND, і подібно до query gate,
ці значення відтворюються
як частина виходу, і значення функції, тобто логічне AND від A та B,
XOR-ується на нижній qubit. Тепер ми не включали Toffoli gates у наш стандартний набір gates.
Ми могли б змінити рішення, якщо хочемо, але нам насправді не потрібно
цього робити, бо альтернативно ми можемо реалізувати Toffoli
gates за допомогою Hadamard gates,
T та T dagger gates
та controlled NOT gates, як ти бачиш тут.
Це зовсім неочевидно,
що саме цей circuit реалізує Toffoli gate, але це так, і ти можеш або повірити мені на слово,
або самостійно все перемножити для додаткової практики, або просто запитати Qiskit або Python
або будь-яке програмне забезпечення для множення матриць, щоб зробити множення за тебе.
І ти можеш ознайомитися з
матеріалами підручника для уроку, щоб побачити, як це зроблено за допомогою Qiskit.
Тепер ми можемо перейти до симуляції Boolean gates за допомогою quantum circuits, і все, що нам для цього потрібно, — це NOT gates,
controlled NOT gates та Toffoli gates.
Ці операції всі є детермінованими, крім того, що вони є унітарними, і іноді ми описуємо
такі операції як оборотні, і фактично
вивчення оборотних обчислень передує квантовим обчисленням, і саме звідти походить вся
ця процедура.
Boolean gates, про які нам потрібно
турбуватися, — це NOT gates, Hadamard gates та FANOUT gates,
і ми покажемо, що ми можемо реалізувати ці gates, або симулювати їх, якщо хочеш,
за допомогою NOT gates,
controlled NOT gates та Toffoli gates.
Щоб бути точним, нам потрібні quantum circuits, які дозволяють нам обчислювати значення Boolean gates, що я щойно згадав,
коли ми подаємо їм qubits в
станах стандартного базису як вхід.
Для довільних квантових станів на вході дія буде визначена
лінійністю, як зазвичай.
Нам не потрібно нічого
особливого робити з NOT gates. NOT gates — це NOT gates, і вони можуть бути реалізовані безпосередньо.
А OR gates можна симулювати
за допомогою Toffoli та NOT gates.
AND gates — прості, особливо з огляду на те, що я щойно казав кілька хвилин тому про те, що Toffoli gates по суті є
реалізаціями query gate
функції AND.
Якщо бути точним, ми можемо ввести новий qubit, ініціалізований в нульовий стан,
і нехай цей qubit буде
цільовим для нашого Toffoli gate, а два вхідних
qubits — керуючими.
Різні назви даються
таким додатковим qubits, які часто вводяться
у квантові обчислення, і я назву їх workspace
qubits просто для вибору назви.
WEBVTT
Наше типове припущення для workspace qubits полягає в тому, що вони починають у нульовому стані, і часто ми можемо повернути
їх до нульового стану
коли закінчимо з ними, але не завжди.
На діаграмі у нас є «кет нуль» всередині пунктирного прямокутника, що вказує на те, що
ініціалізація цього qubit
є частиною процесу, і якщо у тебе немає
свіжого qubit, подібного до цього, ти не зможеш
виконати цю симуляцію.
Нижній вихідний qubit —
це той, який нас цікавить, бо це результат
операції AND, і ми по суті
закінчили з двома іншими
тому вони можуть залишатися всередині блоку.
Фактично, можна навіть уявити, що позбавлення від цих двох qubits є частиною завдання
симуляції цього AND gate,
щось на зразок сміття, яке
потрібно прибрати.
Але так чи інакше, ось як ми
можемо симулювати AND gate.
Тепер, коли ми знаємо, як робити AND gates, ми можемо робити OR gates за допомогою
одного із законів де Моргана.
Якщо поставити NOT gates на два входи та на вихід AND
gate, ти отримаєш OR gate — все так просто.
І останнє — FANOUT, і для нього нам потрібен лише controlled NOT gate разом з workspace qubit.
Зокрема, якщо ми
встановимо workspace qubit як цільовий, ми фактично просто копіюємо будь-який стан стандартного базису, що надходить,
тому це діє як FANOUT gate.
Отже, у нас є всі gates.
І тепер, маючи всі gates, ми можемо перейти до circuits.
Припустимо, що у нас є
якийсь Boolean circuit під назвою C, і це може бути будь-який
Boolean circuit на твій вибір,
за умови, що він складається з
AND, NOT та FANOUT gates.
Нехай T буде кількістю gates в C, і дамо назву F тій функції, яку обчислює C.
Тому ми можемо думати про F як таку, що має вигляд, який ти бачиш тут, де N — кількість вхідних бітів C,
M — кількість вихідних бітів, а sigma — двійковий алфавіт.
І що ми робимо — це просто проходимо по одному через gates C.
Ми залишаємо NOT gates як є і замінюємо інші симуляціями,
які я щойно описав.
Тож якщо C виглядає ось так, то ми отримаємо circuit
R, який виглядає ось так.
На цій діаграмі всі
workspace qubits, які нам потрібні для симуляцій, витягнуті з їхніх блоків і зібрані внизу.
Тому K — це загальна кількість
workspace qubits, які нам потрібні, по одному для кожного gate C, крім NOT gates.
Для виходу R у нас є qubits, що
відповідають виходу C, і тут ці qubits
зображені зверху,
хоча насправді в кінці всього цього не матиме значення,
чи вони зверху чи ні.
Якщо бути точним, припускаючи, що ми запустили R на стані стандартного базису, що відповідає
довільному N-бітному рядку X,
ці M вихідних qubits будуть у стані стандартного базису,
що відповідає F від X.
У нас також є всі залишкові qubits від AND та OR gates.
Нам ще потрібно врахувати їх, і якщо зібрати їх усіх разом, вони будуть в якомусь стані стандартного базису.
Яким би не був стан стандартного базису, він повинен бути якоюсь функцією від рядка X, і ми дамо
цій функції назву G.
Отже, G — це нова функція, що
визначається gates C і говорить нам, у якому стані
знаходяться ці залишкові qubits
після запуску R. G — наступна літера після F, тому це одна причина
назвати цю функцію G,
але ще одна причина назвати її G — це те, що G — скорочення від «garbage» (сміття).
Це все garbage qubits, і зокрема у нас є
два garbage qubits для кожного AND gate та для кожного OR gate.
Загальна кількість gates,
які нам потрібні, є «O великим» від T.
Це тому, що для кожного gate C нам потрібна обмежена кількість quantum gates.
OR gate — найдорожчий. Для нього нам потрібно три NOT gates разом з одним Toffoli gate,
а Toffoli gate коштує нам 15 gates з нашого стандартного набору.
Тому це щонайбільше 18 gates
в R для кожного gate C.
Якщо ти захочеш оптимізувати це, то можеш, але для цілей
грубого асимптотичного аналізу ми можемо просто сказати, що
R має «O велике» від T gates.
Отже, нам вдалося
обчислити ту саму функцію F, яку обчислював оригінальний Boolean
circuit C,
і ми зробили це з вартістю, лінійною від розміру C.
Якщо нас цікавить лише
обчислення цієї функції F, то ми закінчили.
Але, на жаль, у нас є
ці garbage qubits, і ці garbage qubits
загалом зіпсують
інтерференційні патерни, які змушують квантові алгоритми працювати, якщо ми спробуємо використовувати цей
circuit R як підпрограму
всередині більшого квантового алгоритму.
Але ми насправді можемо
позбутися цього сміття, і спосіб зробити це — скористатися тим фактом, що circuit R можна інвертувати,
WEBVTT
або іншими словами, ми
можемо запустити його в зворотному порядку.
Щоб проілюструвати, як це працює, уявімо, що спочатку ми запускаємо R, а потім запускаємо R у зворотному порядку,
що ми можемо позначити як R dagger.
Щоб бути точним, це означає, що ми застосовуємо gates
R у зворотному порядку і беремо обернені
до кожного з gates.
NOT gates, controlled NOT
gates та Toffoli gates насправді є власними оберненими, тому якщо ми думаємо в термінах цих gates,
то R dagger — це дійсно просто R з gates у зворотному порядку.
Але загалом ми завжди можемо запустити будь-який унітарний quantum circuit у зворотному порядку таким чином, як я щойно описав,
тобто ми застосовуємо
gates у зворотному порядку і замінюємо кожен з
окремих gates на його обернений.
Якби ми зробили це, ми б виявили, що спочатку запуск R і потім запуск R у
зворотному порядку не дає нічого.
Тому якщо ми починали у стані стандартного базису, як тут, то ми б закінчили точно в тому самому стані стандартного базису.
Звичайно, просто це зробити
не дуже корисно, але ми можемо ввести купу додаткових qubits і зокрема
це M qubits, де M — кількість вихідних бітів circuit C.
Ці додаткові qubits можуть бути
в будь-якому квантовому стані, але щоб пояснити, як це працює, ми припустимо, що вони у стані стандартного базису,
що відповідає якомусь рядку Y. Отже, Y — це M-бітний рядок, і ми можемо виконати
купу controlled NOT
gates, як ти бачиш тут, що фактично XOR-ує рядок F від X
на рядок Y, що зберігається
в цих нижніх M qubits.
І тому вихід
всього обчислення такий, як показано на екрані.
X і Y — довільні двійкові рядки. X має M бітів, а Y має M бітів, і нам також потрібно K workspace qubits.
Коли ми запускаємо R, ми обчислюємо F від X, і цей рядок зберігається
у верхніх M qubits, але у нас також є купа garbage qubits,
тому ми XOR-уємо вихід F від
X на нижні M qubits, а потім запускаємо R у зворотному порядку
для очищення сміття.
Варто зазначити, що важливо, щоб R був детермінованим.
Якщо ці верхні M qubits могли б замість цього бути в якійсь суперпозиції
станів стандартного базису, це не спрацювало б правильно,
але це працює, коли
R є детермінованим.
Тому, порівнюючи quantum
circuit, який ми щойно побудували, з оригінальним Boolean circuit C, ми бачимо, що він по суті
працює так само,
як query gate
для довільної функції.
Є одна відмінність, яка полягає в тому, що нам потрібні
ці workspace qubits, щоб все це працювало, але в іншому ми
фактично побудували query gate
або query circuit для тієї функції, яку обчислює C.
Крім того, нам вдалося, до речі, повернути workspace
qubits до їхнього початкового стану, тому вони, в принципі, можуть бути повторно використані
як workspace qubits для
наступних обчислень.
Якщо хочемо, ми можемо обгорнути весь quantum circuit і назвати його Q, і зв'язок з
C стає більш зрозумілим.
Circuit Q буде
більшим за C загалом. Нам потрібна жменька quantum
gates у Q для кожного gate C,
і нам також потрібні controlled
NOT gates посередині, але кількість все одно
лінійна від розміру C.
Також варто зазначити, що це повністю загальна процедура, яка працює для будь-якого Boolean circuit, і ми взагалі не намагалися оптимізувати Q.
Для конкретного circuit C може цілком бути
способи зменшити розмір Q, включаючи методи
для зменшення кількості
workspace qubits, якщо це те,
що ми хочемо зробити, і це є процедурою для виконання
класичних обчислень
на квантовому комп'ютері.
Це досить просто, але це важлива
річ, яку треба вміти робити.
Зокрема, тепер, коли
ми знаємо, як це робити, ми вільні використовувати будь-які класичні обчислення,
всередині квантових обчислень, за умови, що ми дотримуємося цієї форми, де вхід відтворюється і вихід XOR-ується
на купу qubits
так само, як ми мали для query gates.
Вартість масштабується лінійно. Тому, наприклад, ми можемо
створювати quantum circuits для задач на зразок цілочисельного додавання,
множення, ділення, обчислення НСД та модульного піднесення до степеня, і все це можна зробити з тією ж асимптотичною вартістю,
що й для Boolean circuits.
Нам потрібні workspace qubits для цього, але принаймні вони доступні для повторного використання, коли
ми з ними закінчимо.
Останнє зауваження, варте уваги, полягає в тому, що цей метод надає нам спосіб реалізовувати query gates,
на що я натякав на попередньому уроці.
Це я й мав на увазі на попередньому уроці.
Тобто, якщо у нас є query алгоритм, що бере деяку функцію F як вхід, і ми маємо спосіб обчислити
F за допомогою Boolean circuit,
тоді ми можемо дотримуватися цієї процедури для побудови query gate для цієї функції та запустити наш query алгоритм на ньому.
Чи є це корисним — залежить від самої query задачі та того, чого ми намагаємося досягти, але по суті ця
конструкція надає нам
спосіб зв'язати модель запитів з більш стандартною моделлю обчислень.
Це певним чином те, як алгоритм Шора для факторизації цілих чисел працює.
WEBVTT
Ми збираємося побудувати
quantum circuits, подібні до цього, з деяких арифметичних операцій, про які ми говорили раніше в уроці.
І роблячи це, ми
надаємо quantum circuits здатність обчислювати ці операції на суперпозиціях класичних станів.
І як ми побачимо, це дозволяє нам ефективно розкладати цілі числа на множники.
Це кінець цього уроку, який головним чином був присвячений закладенню фундаменту
для квантових алгоритмів у стандартній обчислювальній структурі без чорного ящика.
Ми говорили про обчислювальну вартість переважно через призму задач, пов'язаних з базовою теорією чисел.
Ми обговорили поліноміальну
проти експоненційної вартості для обчислювальних задач і побачили, як класичні обчислення
можуть бути реалізовані quantum circuits чистим, без-сміттєвим способом, що дозволяє використовувати їх як підпрограми
всередині більших квантових обчислень.
Сподіваюся, ти приєднаєшся до мене на наступному уроці, де ми побачимо, як алгоритм Шора використовує ці ідеї, дозволяючи нам розкладати
цілі числа на множники з поліноміальною вартістю.
До побачення.